hey there everyone welcome to california
i'm about to show you a moon tree that's
right a moon tree now the moon trees all
over the world not just here they're
mainly in the United States and another
place you can find them is the good
state of Alabama that's where my friend
Destin lives so I asked him if it also
helped me out in what should we call
this operation moon three rolls a brady
i am more than willing to take on this
assignment from you i am pulling up next
to the u.s. space & rocket center right
now we're about to go inside and check
out some Apollo's stuff and talk about
moon trees
ok so what exactly is a momentary well
the moon tree is a tree grown from seeds
that were taken to the moon seeds taken
to the moon basically about 500 seeds
were taken to the moon by an astronaut
called Stuart Roosa. he was the command
module pilot of apollo 14 now before he
was an astronaut, Roosa is what's called a
smokejumper smokejumpers parachute
firefighters one answer to the problem
of fire and remote roadless areas so he
had an association with trees and he was
asked if he'd take these seeds on his
voyage to the moon
he agreed okay check it out this is the
Saturn V. this is what took the seeds
to the moon
we're gonna go to the end of the museum
here and see if we can look at the
Apollo capsule which I wrote the seats
are actually in there not at some point
but i guess we have to return to Earth
want to take it out
alright so this is the apollo 16 command
module so this is not Apollo 14 which is
what the seeds were actually taken on
but still the Apollo program was
forward-thinking often hears a moon rock
by the way. Stuart Roosa didn't
actually walk on the moon that was alan
shepard and edgar mitchell rusev stayed
above in the command module called
kittyhawk basically orbiting the moon
waiting for his buddies to come back he
didn't mess around while he was up there
though he had a lot to do
he actually took a lot of photos of the
Moon and so while the guys were down on
the surface of the Moon these seeds were
going around the moon right there so
that the seeds didn't actually touch
down on the moon but they did go around
the moon after that they went back up a
rendezvoused, and then they came all
the way back and that's when the seeds
went to Mississippi which is where they
started to sprout once they were
sprouted they handed out all over the
nation even to other countries and we're
going to go try to find one of those
trees right now so my moon tree is one
of these here it's actually surprising
sort of how hidden the way it is
you'd think it'd be out on grand display
really important but this one's it's not
easy to find if you don't know what
you're looking for
now unfortunately there were seven here
at the Space and Rocket Center but in
the '80s they died
well I guess that's bound to happen to
some of the trees now where are we
it's around here somewhere i'll tell you
what this is hard work making these
educational YouTube videos
no messing around ok we don't know
exactly where the trees were planted it
was somewhere here at the Space and
Rocket Center so in order to figure out
what the whole grounds look like
erotic space shot oh ok
they're the trees were planted somewhere over
there. not really sure where you like
that
what's your name and I didn't like it i
loved it i was great
oh the seeds were up there they went to
the moon that came back they were
planted somewhere over here and they
died but we're going to see if we can
find a tree that actually survived there
was no countdown or anything good for ya
so we're going to go to Birmingham
Botanical Gardens see if we can find the
only one that I'm aware up here in the
state
let's go check it out keep glasses want
to come and we have liftoff on your part
about working
three minutes past the hour.
all right here we go
are overkill I this is it this is my
moon tree if you don't believe me have
a look at this surprisingly unimpressive
little sign hidden away down here coast
redwood sequoia set pair of errands moon
tree in quotation marks the seed from
which this tree spring was taken to the
moon
how's it going you doing good we're
looking for the moon tree country me
show you
ok let's go find the mention there's a
guy in in England his name is brady he
has an educational YouTube channel and
he's making a video about moon trees and
he sent me up here to find the moon tree. so
could i get seeds from this tree and
have a second generation is that how
that works because we've done it before
we've actually planted seed and we
sent it to a Michigan arboretum so that
leads nicely to the issue of
second-generation omon trees i'm sure you
can figure out what they are these are
the sons and daughters of original moon
trees of this generation moon trace just
take the seeds plant them somewhere else
and it sounds to me like distance
learning himself up for second
generation moon tree in his backyard in
Alabama can we climb in there and see if
we can finally I mean a seed all right
let's go come on let's go mr. Taylor
said we could do you know what movie is
what would you guess the moon tree is a
moon moon moon Trey their branches are
shaped in a crescent
oh that's a good guess it's not right
but it's a good guess now it was grown
from seeds that were taken to the moon
last night
now that I wouldn't have thought
understand
yeah you seen these sycamore see pods I
don't know what they look like you so
Destin's montre that's a sycamore mine
here this is a redwood there were three
other types sweet gums furs and pines
there you moan trees that's the five
types of seeds that Stuart Roosa took to
the moon
I'm gonna touch the bark.
so this tree came from a seed that went
to space not only did go to space went
around the moon we go Destin send you
those bad boys
Brady we're not gonna find any seeds
they keep it to clean around here it
looks like they trimmed at one point in
time and that thing is big isn't it look
about there's the moon there's moon tree
Moon Moon tree Moon Moon tree so I think
school about moon trees is that that
means that seeds are completely
transportable it gets a little unit of
life that goes dormant and you can do
whatever you want with it and it's still
going to work
bruiser mitchell and Shepherd they've
all died now in fact apollo 14 is the
first mission for which all three
astronauts have passed away so it
somehow fitting that they're the ones
that have left us with this legacy of
Apollo. not a statue not a stone or metal
monument but something living and
3 second-generation moon trees and
maybe 3rd 4th 5th generation moon trees
a way that we can always remember one of
humankind's greatest accomplishments
if you've never seen Destin's youtube
channel smartereveryday I'm amazed you
haven't but you really should
it's not only one of the best
educational channels on youtube it's one
of the best channels on youtube . make
sure you check it out
links are on the screen description all
the usual places what i was thinking and
then the eggs back and them could have
chickens but they wouldn't have big legs
so you can eat them just have them as a
pad at the moon again